do I have a debate club for you kiss or
ac/dc
who do you got let me know Gang Gang
buzz buds
kiss already DC can I hear some of their
[ __ ] classics huh
ac/dc Oh hells bells welcome to the
jungle
this is kiss know that that's
everything's been ac/dc so far that
we've said what weight was it did he say
kiss are ac/dc yeah ac/dc man gene
Simmons honestly seems like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] man I feel like gene Simmons is
one [ __ ] bad [ __ ] drug away from
being one of Joe exotic boys always had
that face paint on and [ __ ] and the high
heels not fooling nobody bro yeah I
interviewed his daughter one time she
was less than desirable to be around
what she I met her a few times
she's a dying me though mmm she's
[ __ ] Wooden Nickel yes I don't know
man I wouldn't give you two cents for
her attitude that's for sure but what do
I know you know I'm just an accomplished
young man with a [ __ ] nice [ __ ] do
don't let joy Sonicare Joe exactly now
how are you young man you said you do
got a nice guy no I got me that straight
I want to beat that the Obama exactly
for any reason to make you gay oh how
many letters easy suddenly gonna be
getting in prison dude but he still has
that boyfriend Dylan what's his name
whatever that boy's name is that boy was
in that Camaro SS crying he call him
three times a day God he said don't
worry I can get it out of here we we can
be together
he said I know baby crying these gay
boys man it's a real love story really
really gay though that's the question
yeah they are you think yeah dude I
don't like how you won't admit that that
man is full on my homoerotic I think he
is just law
in troubled man in drug-induced man you
do enough drugs you end up gay man I
talk about it all the time as facts
give me some kiss what kiss best song
what's the number-one song because I'm
not that big of a kiss fan boy doing too
much makeup for me joy talks more
straight than kiss kiss was just more I
agree with that kiss was more what is
the kids out what you say kiss hits
talking kiss all's good wanna rock n
roll yeah I don't know ac/dc destroys
kiss by the way yeah kiss ain't even
close
here's my ass bro
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]